hello everyone and welcome to another
google+ hangout i'm super excited to be
here with you to talk about how to form
strategic partnerships that help you
grow your business and I have a special
guest with me John Walder who works with
Aweber and hey guys super excited to be
here hey Weber is the email software
that I use to send out all my newsletter
that a lot of you guys already on and
John is the business development expert
there and I thought we could pick his
brain and she get some knowledge and I
some ideas direct so John do you want to
just quickly tell people what your role
is there what do you do yeah absolutely
guys and you know thank you again for
having me I'm super excited to be here
and I'll speak with all you incredible
entrepreneurs i guess around the world
and guys just from background on on a
weber if i guess if there's anyone out
there that's not familiar we're an email
service platform we're an email service
platform to roughly about 120,000 small
medium-sized businesses worldwide you
know customers will choose a weber a lot
for like our all-inclusive pricing and
we don't really do an ala carte everyone
gets the same incredible aweber
experience whether you have you know
five subscribers or 500,000 like like
Evan here probably does so yeah and you
know what I do personally with with
Aweber and give you some background kind
of born on my role here and I really
focus on on three like key areas if you
will of the business and that is like
bringing more awareness around a weber
and two people that might be interested
in email marketing so I do that I build
strategic partnerships with other sask
organizations to really just get more
exposure with that brand in front of
their audience and vice versa so I've
been spearheading a project here that
were just calling a weber partner offers
which actually just went live this week
on the website so you guys can
definitely check that out and just being
a point of contact for like a large
volume ascenders with north of say like
twenty-five thousand subscribers or so
very cool so I've always been a fan of
building partnerships and I've
encouraged my rents a lot in the biggest
that I've made saying one of the easiest
way to grow business is to partner up
with people who already have your
audience finds a way to make connections
with them do you have I know we've got
tons of questions but do you have any
like just kind of quick high-level
advice on how to do that reaching out
the potential partners absolutely I do
so when I when I'm speaking with a
potential partner I like to try to keep
the five about five things in mind when
I'm speaking with that potential partner
one's going to be the company values so
really what what what does that company
stand for and do they line up with that
of of aweber or whatever organization
you you're going to be coming from so
for instance Aweber you know work work
committed to creating remarkable
experiences not taking ourselves too
seriously executing with passion things
like that so when I'm speaking with this
potential partner I don't I don't want
to hear off the bat about your bottom
line revenue or what's the rev share
look like or things like this could be
like a red flag off the bat in terms of
maybe we're not going about this from
this from the same point of view and
another thing is the customer symmetry
so are the customer bases do they look
alike I being an email service platform
probably not going to go over and
partner with someone like NASCAR or
someone where this doesn't make sense so
do that doesn't make sense do we have do
we serve the same customer base what
does our ideal customer look like so
having the data to support that and
knowing what your ideal customer looks
like it's very important another thing
you want to keep in mind is just long
term commitment so you don't want any
fly-by-nights in terms of a partnership
you really want someone that's going to
come to the table with ideas and they're
in it for the long haul so they're
committed to the co-marketing the
co-branding that's going to be involved
and really making this thing work
because at the end of day you're really
going to get out of it what you you're
putting into it and results
how are you going to track results how
are we going to how are you going to
know what a successful partnership looks
like so having those KPIs key
performance indicators known ahead of
time to be able to to track and how do
you track that so that's that's some
things that that I keep in mind when
when I'm speaking with potential
partners another thing about my include
as well you ever get your input maybe
you do too but is this having an out
clause to because it can be tricky
speaking about okay well what if this
marriage doesn't work and it could be it
could make for a little bit of a sticky
situation so you want to be able to
address that upfront so when you come
you know two three months down the road
with this partnership and it's just not
working well now you have agreed upon
terms at the beginning of this
partnership it says you know what let's
both just walk away and end this thing
amicably I love it and John wrote a
really cool article that I shared in the
description that kind of went on those
five points a little more detail as well
that you guys can check out your
convenience for those of you watching
may have notices a chat box on the right
side if you have a question for me or
John you can leave it there and we'll do
our best to get at them because I know a
lot of them are coming in so let's get
to it let's get your questions the first
one was from Team bossy gals wrote in to
say I'd like to know how to effectively
use leverage to target my market get
qualified leads on my list and make them
by what do you think John I love this
one uh soso team bossy thank you for for
sending this in early and the early bird
gets the worm so I had the chance to go
out and look at your website which looks
tremendous by the way and you know the
one thing that I did notice off the bat
team boss he was what at least for my
experience of my web experience from
coming to the site I wasn't greeted with
a pop-up signup form to capture my email
address now I'm just coming from you
know the email marketing side of the
world here when I when I speak about
this but there's two reasons why I think
this is a huge missed opportunity here
for you bossy one is fifty-five percent
Lee of site visitors are going to be on
your site for an average of under 15
seconds so it's really important to make
the most of this time when they come to
your site to be able to capture them to
be able to go back and market to them
down the road that's the one and you
know too according to some some data
that's out there from what one from our
partner a weber corner crazy egg there
pop-ups are going to drive roughly about
thirteen hundred percent more email
signups than other forms of signup forms
that you can put on your site rather or
something like that so yeah thirteen
hundred percent it's nothing too in the
same lightly out right so yeah so yeah
this definitely something you could do
with you know to Oleg ours or just
countless others out there that you can
use but something to definitely keep in
mind i guess in terms of your in terms
of your website traffic so yeah i just
want to throw that out there and
everyone if you had anything else maybe
that ad on that yeah you know in terms
of collecting emails i like to see
business as a relationship and trying to
date before you get married you know
you're going to walk up to somebody on
the street and say will you marry me and
a lot of people try to go for the
clothes too soon on a website and if you
can just build a relationship capture
their email address and then have a way
to follow up with them then duck provide
them with value build a trust
relationship than much more likely to
buy from you then closing on sale right
away from the start so yeah everyone on
one thing i would just add thereto oven
is i noticed was the only on your site
you had great content i think you you
have it segmented into like five
distinct category there's over 50 single
mom i forget the others off the top of
my head but when you serve that pop-up
form you could be able to to then ask
that visitor what they're interested in
and beat you provide check boxes in
those checkboxes cuz then correspond
back to the collateral or the content
that they receive moving forward so
someone throw out there keep in mind and
but again great site i think i thought
it looked awesome cool next up joshua
davis wrote in the say i need a lot of
help with marketing monk tutoring
business and with establishing
complimentary strategic partnerships all
right
another another early bird to jaw Evan
you got a lot of early birds which is
incredible um so full disclosure Josh I
I don't know neck I know next to nothing
about about tutoring I'll just put it up
put that out there but as I as I was
thinking about that and I was finding
myself going to google to google
tutoring businesses I was just thinking
myself well how many other people know
next to nothing about tutoring or
probably doing the same thing that I'm
doing here is just googling and if
anyone's familiar out there with the
likes of a patch fling or someone like
that smart passive income this is
something that they make their tons of
tons of monthly recurring revenue on
it's just having no sites that are just
content kings and just really speak well
to the content that people are looking
for so this might be an idea josh is
just one of the ideas I had for you in
terms of just being able to have a site
that speaks to the content that people
are searching for and then some other
verticals that you might want to hash
out and really look into is this the
educational software a vertical I know
education software is popping up
everywhere I have a one-year-old in
daycare that uses a total tadpoles that
sends us emails throughout the day
letting us know how the children are
doing what they're up to so it's
everywhere starting at one years old so
I'm sure that there's there's others out
there that you can you can reach out to
and partner up with yeah i'm i'm on
board with that too and i think what i
love the sea is is showing your passion
for the business like why do you care
about your doing do you have your own
kids tell me the story behind it because
a lot of you i have i have a
six-year-old son and I've seen some of
the tutoring websites and they all kind
of seen the same yeah they all seem very
impersonal where if you showed me like a
real human being your story your kids
you know delighted clients ah that's
going to help make you stand out at
least in my mind and if you're reaching
out the customers or partners or media
having a store that they can tell
easily that separates you from everybody
else I think that passionate store can
help be the differentiator for you
absolutely cool next a thule hi evan i
need help with marketing p lv systems
while you were talking i was looking up
what elb systems work because they
didn't know um and i think it stands for
if I found the right one is extra-low
voltage and so it's things electronics
at security cameras and microphones and
home fire alarms that are super low
voltage and he's I guess trying to
market these to his clients yeah I would
say that's definitely someone that fits
well within our wheelhouse in terms of
who we serve and from from a customer to
Stan base we're really going you're
going you're going to see a lot of our
customers come from a web based business
they're going to be a blogger someone
that may be a small brick and mortar
store owner so that's definitely
something we consist with and we'll be
able to happily assist you know if you
wanted to send out an email to myself
for Patrick that's in it in the chat
window here we'd be happy to assist in
terms of letting you know if it's
something we could help you out with
yeah and in terms of marketing um that
kind of product I would look at
partnerships who are people buying from
before they buy from you so if you're
installing a home security system could
you partner up with builders for example
right there building all these new homes
there's an e could you partner up with
them and be the preferred choice of
extra low voltage security systems I'd
be looking at everybody in my chain you
know my customers who are they buying
from before they buy for me and
introducing myself to them as a
potential partner and senior might be
able to work together right um segera
ronald rights then help me in marketing
my christian radio station so John Young
heart of a Christian radio station how
you going to market it that that that's
a good one
they're trying to think of customers
that we have in terms of the media inter
and and how how that they partner up and
whom that that might be with I mean the
first thing that's coming to my to my
head is just local local church groups
and religious organizations have have
you done your due diligence there inside
of your area just just making sure that
these people are on your on your list
your email list and maybe segmenting
them a certain way by by way of what
their interests are you know something
something to consider there yeah i would
look at to uh what influencers you can
work with I'd look at who some of the
John's point like who are the people
influential in your community but also
on I would look on a national scale to
who are the people who are really
influential in the Christian community
we're really outspoken who's really
popular on YouTube when really popular
on Facebook and Twitter and really
kicking up a storm and I would try to
have them on as guess for my show so I
don't know a lot about you know
Christian leaders but if I was doing
this for the entrepreneur space I might
have Gary Vaynerchuk on my show I might
have marie forleo on my show i might try
to get big CEOs who've done great things
with their companies i love that howard
schultz on my show and so I look at who
is super popular and trending and has an
opinion in the Christian space and try
to have them on as guest for your show
cuz a lot a lot of credibility and also
hopefully help spread the word for you
um dxt premier I have a startup company
that hires out cooling equipment for
outdoor events Marquis and so forth I
need help with marketing the company
cooling equipment for events we got
we've got people all over the place
where John I'm getting some great
business ideas I would go right to the
the big event planners again starting in
your area there and just finding out you
know who they are and it was signing up
further there may be their email
newsletters reaching out and having some
correspondence there and
and letting you know about your service
and kind of how can you partner up that
that just seems like seems like a
no-brainer I guess maybe just other
other ideas catering different catering
companies that working inside of outdoor
venues you know is there anyone there
where you can really leverage a
relationship and get get more leads from
these strategic partners that that
you're finding inside your area yeah I I
agree man I think it's similar to the
previous question before about the low
voltage system stuff its partnerships
with people who are in that same chain
so who are people buying from before
they buy from you so i love the event
planners i love the caterers this is a
very local business and i think you
could reach out to them and ask for a
coffee and see how you might be able to
help each other out it's a lot easier
asking for like a partnership meeting to
brainstorm ideas I might be able help
each other out then trying to sit down
and say hey I want to I want to sell you
my product and talking to a customer bio
me absolutely is because i personally i
do both and i would the partnership
discussions just just seemed to be a lot
more casual and just letting them know
about your service and one thing that
also works for me and you might work for
you as well but when i when i reach out
to a potential partner and i'm having
that discussion or maybe haven't even
had the discussion yet finding out who
are their partners and it's kind of just
it kind of just connects you with to see
okay what local organizations are they
are the members of is their local event
organizations or catering organizations
different dot orgs that they're members
of so look at the bottom of a lot of the
websites that you're reaching out to and
look for their memberships and
organizations that they belong to yeah
love it love it um dread dog riding in I
like the named red dog good dog is a
loyal YouTube viewer comments on tons of
my videos uh this is a different angle
so he wants to know how much time do you
spend researching a company before you
go and jump in and or you learn by doing
it just going and research a lot what's
your approach yeah definitely it you
have to have a strategic vision in terms
of who are you
I need to partner with and why I can
speak personally from from Aweber the
Branson organizations that we're trying
to partner with are for the most part
SAS organizations that cater to SMB
owners of which Aweber is part of their
email marketing strategy so again coming
back to the previous question evan is
when I reach out and I hone in on that
partnership that I'm seeking out and
trying to get in front of who have they
partnered with in the past and looking
at those different relationships that
they've struck up so that's that's
that's one part of it so in terms of the
I guess the due diligence that you have
to do beforehand it's a lot you really
need to come it has to be part of a
strategic vision a higher higher picture
strategic vision but also on that on
that actual partner doing your your work
around linkedin and seeing seeing who's
connected there a google news search to
see if they were they were recently
maybe quoted somewhere having any
anything going on within the
organization something that you can
reference when you when you reach out
yeah I always what I'm doing
partnerships I always like to work with
companies that I know something about or
I use them in some way there's some kind
of personal connection to it and that's
usually the starting point so so even
like this like this is a partner should
I break between me and a weber I man
Aweber client I've been using Aweber for
10 years or something ridiculous I
recommend it to anybody who asked you an
email software and so I forget how we
even open up this conversation but it's
easy for me to talk to you guys because
i'm a customer we serve the same
audience it doesn't feel like anybody
selling each other it just feels like a
natural fit because i have a personal
and a vested interest in familiarity you
know it's funny I actually went in in
preparing for this this discussion I
actually went back and saw some of the
email communication between Evan and the
other members of a weber I wasn't Evan
in myself that initiated the
conversation
and just just to let people know and if
what I noticed was there was value inn
in the touch point when when Evan would
reach out so he knew something about a
weber he knew something about what we
were trying to do by way of our
marketing initiatives he tied that into
the value he could bring to a weber and
i just thought it was really cool to see
that actually in in motion and coming
here today because it was that line of
communication it was that initial
discussion was an initial outreach that
really set the tone and and provided the
value of what Evan could bring and vice
versa and they away however can bring
you in and having the partnership cool
well I appreciate that um ok on your
email I look at a lot of emails Evan
side wanted to give you some props there
I'm glad that out of all those emails
mine stood at that thanks good that
means something yeah um Anne Marie Cox
what are your thoughts on purchasing
leads to create new business oh ma I'm
gonna I'm gonna come out strong on this
one and say it's a real no no what we
what I can tell you this is this from
from the email marketing side of things
again is I speak slowly from that but
when you boil it down what you're
looking for in an email is is subscriber
engagement now when that subscriber
comes to your site and and clicks it in
an dobson to receiving your
communication and you send them an email
to confirm that subscription and you're
really starting that that journey and
you're really growing with that customer
and your thus increasing the likelihood
of higher subscriber engagement and a
conversion down the road whether that be
a purchase a vote it could be a million
different things when when you purchase
leads you have none in that you don't
know what you're getting into and from
email service providers framework many
of the email service providers out there
actually won't even be able to work with
you I know for a fact they Weber cannot
work with anyone that's purchased a list
or any type of leads
so I say it's you're better off building
your your list over a long haul that are
your building from a higher echelon if
you will of subscribers that are engaged
in to what you're saying or what you're
selling then you are going out and
purchasing purchasing a lesson Evan what
were your thoughts there yeah yeah I'm
with you on that um I like you know
doing the Golden Rule you treat people
like you'd like to be treated and I hate
being spammed so why would I span people
I hate being cold called why would I
cold call people okay I mean I guess it
can work for some people and I think
it's becoming less and less and less
effective but I try to do things that
I'm I would be receptive to if I saw it
I'll throw a curveball and I a friend of
mine is doing something interesting
where he is using lists in a different
way he'll buy a list of names so C is
trying to target fire fighters for
example goodbye our list firefighters
and you'll never email them but he'll
upload the list to facebook so you can
track and he'll show targeted ads when
they come on facebook okay so it's a
slightly different way of doing it and
and if I go on Facebook you know I don't
mind seeing ads related to
entrepreneurship but I definitely
wouldn't want you emailing me or calling
me I don't have a phone I just have a
voicemail yeah I don't have a cell phone
either um and that's maybe going kind of
extreme but I don't like to being
interrupted which would it all comes
down to and so you know you are
interrupting your potential clients
you're starting off uh you know on a
negative note which yet I really hate so
i'm not a big i'm not a big fan um co we
were talking about Theo just before we
started this so Theo wrote in to say
what signs do you think you need to keep
in mind when picking a business partner
you can trust and I think this could
also apply to what you may be implying
is like a partner for your business as
opposed to like an alliance partnership
so what do you think yeah I think it's
just coming back to it it's just
probably those five different
if you want to call them that just
having that in the back of your mind
when you're when you're entering into
that discussion and if if at any point
along the way anything kind of just
feels off doesn't feel right I i would i
would balk on that on that partnership
least I do personally that's really kind
of how I start things out and kind of to
see where they progress but it's
important to come to the table with I
guess an idea of the value that you
bring to that organization and having
those things mapped out for instant what
does that co-marketing look like so you
might have things in mind terms of Q&A
sessions like what we're doing here
today or potential webinar or a blog
post things of value that show that
partner that you know you've done you've
done the due diligence and you've taken
the time to really map out that
long-term commitment what that looks
like to them that's really going to you
know speak to to that partnership and
another think that the keep in mind is
when you're when you're having a
partnership discussion and you're coming
to an agreement on a partnership is
you're really investing as much as much
in that person or team as you are in the
company or the brand that are behind so
you really want to get a sense of having
a good rapport there and a good working
relationship because that's really going
to be your point of contact as you kind
of build this thing out yeah and John
kind of mentioned the five pillars so
those are you joining late he wrote an
awesome article about that on linkedin
that is in the description you guys can
check that out later on yeah my view is
uh I think a lot of people rush into
partnerships because it looks good on
paper but the values don't align yeah
and that was the number one point and
then you brought up before and if you're
hiring a co-founder for your business or
if you want to make a partnership with
another company is just an alliance it
can make total sense on paper and
there's a lot of brands that have come
to me who say Evan we want to sell that
entrepreneurs you of entrepreneurs let's
partner up and just their approach is
just totally wrong and their values are
totally different than what I believe in
right you know may look great on paper
and if you're hiring a co-founder he may
have all the skills that you need but if
you don't the same values you're never
going to work out and
a lot of people just rush into
partnerships because it looks good on
that paper but it doesn't work out
because the values don't match exactly i
mean the the value of a partnership are
the results and what it what it brings
whether that be for your customers or
whatever your your end result you want
that to be so if if you're doing all
this work that this yield doesn't yield
the results then it's it's important to
be able to identify that up front is be
able to cut bait say you know what this
probably is one is going to be worth all
the time and investment on both our ends
so you know thanks but no thanks yeah
and uh you know to throw a little cheese
on top of it um in working with with
Aweber I found everybody to be really
nice just like nice people um and I like
working with nice people and I think
that's why it's worth having you know I
want will mean people beside it work you
got everybody I've met in the
organization is just a really nice
person and I'm probably comes from the
founder down and that's part of the
culture you guys are building and that
works with my style and so everything
can look great on paper but we also kind
of match up with the same values and so
that's why I'd be looking for in a
start-up partner or just an alliance
partner for your business ah Valerie is
writing in hi oven and John how and
where can we attract high-end interior
designers for our luxury furniture
platform what kind of topics would be
interested in for high-end b2b leads so
try and attract high in interior
designers for a luxury furniture
platform yeah I would again i would
start and on the research for this phase
of things and really doing the due
diligence online and figuring out the
associations and organizations that are
attributed to that to the high-end brand
or vertical that you want to really get
involved with and market too so it's
starting there and just figuring you're
reaching out to those to those
organizations if people are using
linkedin premium and be able to send in
males to decision-makers at the
different organization
that's something I use here at a Weber
is it is a little bit of an investment
on your end but I think at the end of
the day it's well worth those
discussions that you might be able to
establish and kind of doing doing
something like that speaking of which
some other I guess cool tools if you
want to call them that that i use in
terms of trying to break into
organizations like that the linkedin
premium is certainly one thing that i
found huge there's a app called similar
web that you might want to check out
it's a google chrome extension so it
gives you the lot about that that
website in that domain so when you come
to Evan Carmichael com using similar web
you're able to see where he ranks in
terms are where Evan ranks in terms of
the is Alexa ranking both domestic and
international another cool thing about
that it gives you a similar
organizations or similar websites that
you might want to be able to target to
so definitely check out that that's
something that again it's really just
finding that rule that one potential
partner and be able to branch out from
there I think you can use that in all
across the board in terms of your
research and going after other potential
targets that you want to go after yeah
to add to that I would look for a name
brand that I would put on my hit list as
kind of the ideal person I want to be
partnered up with and that person can
help bring a lot more attention to your
brand yeah for me when I was launching
my website to have content for
entrepreneurs I want a Donald Trump
because at the time he had the
apprentice show it was not one field for
entrepreneurs and everything I built up
was working towards getting Donald Trump
and so I started with friends who were
authors nikka break for the site and I
use their names to get Seth Godin Guy
Kawasaki and then use their names yet
keep moving up the list and eventually
got the Donald Trump and then from there
just we hit the tipping point where all
of these big name people were involved
we didn't have to market anymore people
just want to come and contribute so if
there's high-end designers like who's
top high-end designer you want to go
after and then work your path to them
and once you get that person involved
you have this whole backup of other
people as well you built all this
mentum the marking almost experiments
off because you have this huge
credibility behind you yeah and you can
also decide that Evan you cannot what
you could do is to settle for go set
yourself up with google alerts for those
companies so you're getting notified
when something happens there or again
you want to sign up for their their
newsletters and see how their marketing
themselves and and maybe what their
messaging looks like in the content
that's being provided in those
newsletters that's something that we do
here in terms of following who are big
targets are I love that and follow them
on Twitter and follow them on YouTube
and engage their stuff you should be a
known quantity to them John I know we
said half an hour we're already a half
an hour Rory 101 how are we doing how we
doing on time what do you want to do
yeah I have you know five ten minutes if
there's other questions that we we
haven't gotten gotten to out there deaf
yet there's lots of questions so you
tell me when you got to go and we'll
wrap it up ankle I might stick around
after just to help people a little bit
more on her win is asking a weber
question so this is great how can a
weber help us market our natural healing
brain for chronic pains and help us
market internationally what steps should
we make Irwin yeah so or when a lot of
its going to come back to one are using
email marketing right now and how are
using the email marketing with what the
subscribers that you have if you're not
using email marketing then you'll be
able to you really just grow from the
ground up using a tool like aweber
whoever you use but coming back to it
you want to the focus of using an email
service provider is to build a healthy
sustained list people you want people on
that list that are going to be engaged
on with the content that you're
providing them so at the end of the day
that's that's really what it's going to
boil down to is you want a healthy list
of people that have opted in the
receiving your communications now if you
don't have that currently by all means a
weber could certainly you know help you
get there and you know Patrick or
reaching out to just a weber com will
certainly be able to assist with you
uh you know we offer 33 30-day trial is
something you wanted to kick the tires
on but coming back to it it's really
going to be being it's a self-service
tool you're going to get out of it what
you put into it and we do have our live
customer solutions team here that's
available seven days a week you know to
help you out with building campaigns and
executing but our focus is going to be
on growing your business through a very
healthy subscribed are healthy and some
subscriber base I got tongue-tied there
that's okay we ever had any water yet
you know I feel like my throat's drying
up I know I buy my water here good Oh
minor you all talks you can drink um my
thoughts here is at focus on education
ah the great thing about using a tool
like aweber is to educate your clients
and build a trusting relationship so if
you're dealing with natural healing
products and chronic pains I would try
to create a weekly newsletter that talks
about issues that people are going
through and how they can overcome them
and not just always hard selling and
saying here buy my product because
people can unsubscribe the great value
that you can provide them if it's a new
chronic pain or a new way of treating
something a new research that came out
or how you're healing products can can
help people are showing customer
examples and stories you know you should
be proud of every email that goes out
and knowing that even if they don't buy
from that email they're still getting
value that way people look forward to
opening every message that comes from
you and when you build that trusted
relationship they're much more likely to
come to you first when they're ready to
buy yeah absolutely I just to add to
that and when you're talking
specifically about email you constantly
have to be adding to that list too
because the stat that's out there is
your email list is going to going to
depreciate on average about twenty-five
percent each year and Evan you could
probably a tribute to this as well so
it's so important that your the content
and the newsletters that you're
providing our value and they speak to
your to your audience and what they've
opted into receiving so that's just
something to keep in mind too yeah good
test that i like to think about is if
you didn't send an email if you have a
weekly email
you forgot to send it one week would
people right in complaining and asking
where's the newsletter like are you that
important to them there's been some
weeks where I've been away a bit on
vacation I just haven't had time to send
an email and people writing to say I
didn't get your email what happened can
you please make sure this good stuff
right like that's how important your
email needs to be to people's lives and
yes the purpose is to then sell them and
whatever product you have but make sure
there's so much great value that they
look forward to receiving this every
week or every month or whatever it is
and and that if it didn't come they
would email you to say what happened to
it that's a good sign I mean you're
doing something right so that's great
cool I know we're kind of way over for
you John so um yeah I think I'm still
good okay okay good we'll go to get
kicked out um akshay wrote in talking
about how do you he wants advice on how
to sell real estate how do you market
yourself in real estate a awesome
question is actually a campaign that
we're going to be rolling out here
shortly and coming back to your your
point from a moment ago having up with
the newsletter so if you're a real a
realtor selling real estate you want to
be able to provide the different
properties or lots to that prospective
customer base that you have so your top
of mind within the conversation and and
they're ready to buy and even post
purchase that you're keeping your
keeping your stay in front of mine in
terms of their referrals and and maybe
they're looking for an investment
property or so forth down the road but
now it's funny too because we're
actually about to kick off a campaign
related to that here very shortly
because we see a lot of Realtors using
Aweber and it's something that we think
we could provide a lot of value there so
stay tuned definitely opt into to our
blog or our mailing list because there's
there's going to be some announcements
coming down the road about that good
question i think for real estate agents
to better market yourself I think the
partnerships could definitely work you
know you want to partner up with the
banks and the you know insurance
companies and anybody related to real
estate that can definitely help I think
the thing that most Realtors suck at is
telling your story there's so many
realtor
is it's ridiculous yeah it's got to be
one of the most competitive industry out
there and everybody just put in their
face on signs and saying I'm the best
I'm the top 1% soul and and I can't tell
the difference between you and everybody
else where if you can tell your story
and make me actually care and feel
something towards you then I'm much more
likely to want to go with you over
everybody else so why do you
passionately care about real estate why
did you get into this business what do
you like to do for your clients and
don't talk to me in a marketing kind of
way like every other agent does talk to
me as a human being like you actually
care about my needs what I'm going
through if you could do that and create
that personal trust then man you'll
scoop up a ton of business yeah and I
think depart from a partnership
perspective to the different angles
maybe staging companies reaching out to
local staging companies in your area
that stage real estate might be
somewhere to look too if you haven't
already yeah great point azam well he
has a gwan new statue in the back yes
legendary Chinese warrior Guan Yu right
here Joseph I I've always approached
others to partner with me in business
what do I miss that these people do not
approach me so I guess he's always out
pitching people who know what is coming
to him how does he fix that it's joseph
great great question joseph in terms of
me personally with my results i know i
get a lot more no sense No thank yous or
the dreaded no response then I will a
conversation so so don't be discouraged
and definitely keep going but coming
back to it it's really want to be you
want to be able to be discoverable and
you want to be providing content
something of value to to that customer
base and to that those partnerships that
you're trying to establish I think
that's so important so just just keeping
great content and on your site within
your newsletters it's going to be really
important their video is definitely one
thing where that i would i would
encourage you to to take full advantage
of as well too but yeah I mean any
thoughts on that yeah I would go all in
on what you're good at for me
I actually I'm a pretty shy person may
not come across and these videos and
everything but I'm very introverted and
so for me doing sales calls and cold
calling people and networking I hate it
I suck at it I don't want to get better
at it no interest it's tough o Allah I
would bring on John to help me if I need
maybe ROM so you know if my business
depended on that for me to be successful
I would fail luckily there's a lot of
different ways to be successful and in
my approach is to try to kick up as much
noise and provide as much value as
possible in my industry so people come
to me I do that through my youtube
channel right we'll do two and a half
million views this month on the channel
instead of going to conferences and
being a member I'm speaking at
conferences and then afterwards people
come to me and ask me questions that
want to do kind of partnerships so I
just try to kick up as much noise as I
can provide as much value as I can doing
what I'm really good at and that
attracts people to be a part of what I'm
doing I think a big part of that is
being authentic and genuine I tell my
story a lot I share personal examples I
love entrepreneurs you know I hope that
comes through and everything that I'm
doing and that attracts kind of the
right kind of people to my business
instead of me having to go out and head
on but that works for me it doesn't work
for everybody yeah just just do do it
once and do it really good and just do a
case study or refer back to that to that
partnership and be able to send that out
to the next partnership that you're out
there seeking it show that partner that
you've done it before and this was the
results that's something that we a day
wherever here do as well with with
partnerships or if that's just different
customers as well on a follow-up
question from Irwin who was asking but
they were before wrote yes we have a
website we'd like to use Aweber to widen
our scope of possible clients and make a
personal partnership for every client we
make contact with can Aweber help us do
that absolutely absolutely can yeah so
or when if you wanted to again just you
know reach out and happy to set you up
with that the free trial account or
speak more about your business first and
foremost and and certainly just get a
better understanding of the right
package how we can we can assist with
your organization so yeah I think that's
that's the like the biggest benefit is
you can turn these people who are
prospects who common and may bounce on
your website in that first 15 seconds
and you can turn that into a
relationship that should that in my view
that should be the goal anybody who
comes to my website my goal isn't to
sell them anything my goal is just to
get them on my newsletter even my
youtube channel right wool is to get
them to go to my newsletter not
subscribe to my channel go to my
newsletter and subscribe so I have
permission to contact you and continue
to send you down and build the
relationship so that I think it's a
great goal for any any website any
business is you want everybody them
comes ideally to sign up for your
newsletter and then send them great
content on going to build a relationship
exactly and you really just it's all
about making the most of that conversion
once that that site visitor gets to your
website because think about you've done
so much and you probably invested so
much just to get that that visit and
here's another step that to throw out
there seventy percent of site traffic to
your sleep actually won't return to so
you got seventy percent of traffic not
coming back now you have fifty-five
percent of those visitors staying for
under 15 seconds and and that number
just keeps coming down here by years so
23 years that might be a 10 seconds you
have to really ultimately make that
visitor the side is this is this someone
I want to do business with and engage
with and sign up for their newsletter or
not or i'm going to bounce out off the
site you know i love it sherry wrote in
hello everyone what is the best way to
approach organizations who i partnered
with in the past i have a difficult
situation i can provide their members
value so which other people you partner
with in the past yeah i think that just
comes back to you know having that
long-term commitment that long-term
vision up front maybe even coming back
to having that out clause so if that
partnership isn't working out and it's
really not yielding the results that you
wish for and it might be time to frankly
just move on to another partnership
that's really going to bring those
results Oh
quite honestly so you really have to
come to a point where it's going to
you're going to have to make that
determination is it is this something I
really want to keep investing my time
and effort into back into or would i be
better served maybe going out and
finding that that next partnership that
that's right for my business so Evan you
might have a different point of view
there but yeah well I'm going to what
happened like how did the partnership
fall apart did the contact person leave
you know that you change your business
and our going back did you end on good
terms or not you know you know if you
ended on bad terms gonna be hard to go
back from an observe it but if it was
good and maybe you just took a break for
a while or your main contact person left
what I would try to do is reach out to
who you think is the appropriate person
and share what you if you ready have a
relationship with them share what you've
done in the past already that opens the
door a lot easier apart from the obvious
of reaching back to the person that you
connected with before I'm assuming that
persons not there or some problem there
but clearly showing the benefits that
you provided them before and everybody
was happy and moving forward and seeing
if there might be a way to continue
working together um Hector well time for
probably one more question here Evan and
I'm gonna have to take it off here
perfect Hector from a psychological
point of view how would you stay focused
when you're having good results instead
of being too confidence active you're
speaking to a what I'd like to consider
myself a confident sales guy and I
thought you were gonna ask how do you
stay confident when you're not getting
good results which is probably the
harder thing I think those two
curveballs there I like it Hector uh I
tried it everything I do Hector me
personally I I keep myself to a 30 day
cycle that might be coming back to
having you know ten plus your sales
career which I'm quite sure it probably
does but I want to be certain that I
have a call a pipeline or call it a
roadmap or forecast but I want to make
sure that i'm always when that deal
closes or partnership closes whatever it
might be
that there's something coming next and
what that looks like so you really have
to just build your own internal pipeline
in and stay committed to that because it
is easy to get caught up in the winds
and say oh you know it's the fist of the
month and i'm already looking great or
whatever your case scenario might be you
really have to think long term and think
ahead that's that's the thing that kind
of just drives me and keeps me focused
and what what is it for you you think um
I like having people in my network who
can kick my ass you know keep my head in
check um because a lot of pouches going
really well for me like the YouTube
channels exploding and got a book deal
lots of great things but you know I have
a mastermind group of other
entrepreneurs and we meet every month
and and I'll I'll say how well
everything's going you're like well how
can it be better than that you know why
aren't you here right what's your
stretch little great that you hit your
goal but what's the stretch goal or how
do you get there and it's got a
challenge I'm going to do more I have an
agent who helps me with my videos and
helps me become a better speaker and
every week he looks at my videos and
sends me feedback and tells me all the
things that need to be fixed and worked
on so even I think wow that was a great
video he'll give me like the 10 things
that were wrong and I gotta get better
at you productive and I appreciate that
so you have people in your network I
think who can kick your ass and give you
you bring you back down to reality um
who encouraged you who don't say you
suck you know but who can can make you
see that you could be much bigger than
you are where I think a lot of
entrepreneurs they there they're the you
know they've done the most in their
environment you never want to be that
person you want to have people around
you who encourage you to be more and who
see a bigger future for you then then
you might even see for yourself I'm
super helpful yeah and that you know for
for myself I always keep an eye on the
comp my competition too and you know
just being able to to gauge what they're
doing how they're doing that really
drives me as well because if if they're
doing something well well you know I
want to make damn sure that I'm doing
that even better but by this time next
month so love it ah
John's gotta go I appreciate the the the
bonus time you gave us today this one
great and thank you so much and you know
to everybody that's joined and you know
you guys are awesome thanks so much for
the questions if there's anything I
could do to assist in any regard please
reach out or contact Devon anything I
can do to help definitely take advantage
of me yeah jaaneman I know you're not
seeing the chat but people are saying
like brilliant great tips thank you so
much so people really getting the value
that you gave there this is part of an
ongoing series that I'm doing with a
weber where every month we're going to
be doing a different topic and the link
to the schedule is in the description so
you guys can join in next month to join
in and bring your questions so thank you
guys for watching thank you John for
joining and we'll see everybody soon
awesome thanks guys take care